MICHALE FEE: OK, good
morning, everyone.
So today, we're going to
continue with our plan
for developing a
powerful set of tools
for analyzing the temporal
structure of signals,
in particular a periodic
structure and signals.
And so this was
the outline that we
had for this series
of three lectures.
Last time, we covered Fourier
series, complex Fourier series,
and the Fourier transform,
discrete Fourier transform.
And we started talking
about the power spectrum.
And in that section,
we described
how you can take any
function and write it as a--
or any periodic
function and write it
as a sum of
sinusoidal component.
So even functions we can write
down as a sum of cosines.
And odd functions we can
write down as a sum of sines.
Today, we're going to
continue with that.
We're going to talk about the
convolution theorem, noise
and filtering Shannon-Nyquist
sampling theorem
and spectral estimation.
And next time, we're
going to move on
to spectrograms and an important
idea of windowing and tapering,
time bandwidth product, and
some more advanced filtering
methods.
So last time, I gave you
this little piece of code
that allows you to compute
the discrete Fourier transform
using this Matlab function FFT.
And we talked about how in
order to do this properly,
you should first
circularly shift.
You have to take
the time series.
And actually, the
FFT algorithm is
expecting the first half of
the data in the second half
of that data vector.
Don't ask me why.
But we just do a circular
shift, run the FFT.
And then circular shift again
to get the negative frequencies
in the first half of the vector.
And then you can plot
the Fourier transform
of your function.
This shows an
example where we took
a cosine as a function of time.
At some frequency,
here, 20 hertz.
We compute the Fourier
transform of that and plot that.
So that's what this looks like.
Here is a cosine at 20 hertz.
And you can see if you take the
fast Fourier transform of that,
you can see that what
you see is the real part
as a function of frequency.
It has two peaks, one at plus
20 hertz, one at minus 20 hertz.
And the imaginary part is 0.
So we have two peaks.
One produces a
complex exponential
that goes around the unit
circle like this at 20 hertz.
The other peak produces
a complex exponential
that goes around the
other way at 20 hertz.
The imaginary parts
cancel and leave you
with a real part that goes
back and forth at 20 hertz OK?
So that's what those
two peaks are doing.
Here is the Fourier transform
of a sine wave at 20 hertz.
This is phase shifted so the
cosine is a symmetric function
or an even function.
The sine is an odd function.
And you can see
that in this case,
the Fourier transform
again has two peaks.
In this case, the
real part is 0.
And the two peaks are
in the imaginary part.
The one at plus 20
hertz is minus I.
And the one at minus
20 hertz is plus I.
Now, the interesting
thing here, the key thing,
is that when you
take the Fourier
transform of a function,
symmetric functions, even
functions, are always real.
The Fourier transform of even
functions is always real.
The Fourier transform,
if you will,
the Fourier series
of the even part
of the function into the real
part of the Fourier transform
and the Fourier
series of the odd part
of the function into the
imaginary part of the Fourier
transform.
OK?
Now, we introduced the idea of
a power spectrum, where we just
take the Fourier transform.
And we take the square magnitude
of that Fourier transform.
And you can see that the power
spectrum of the sine and cosine
function is just a single peak
at the frequency of the sine
or cosine.
OK?
And you can see why that is
because the sine and cosine
have a peak at plus 20 hertz.
For the cosine, it's real.
And for the sine,
it's imaginary.
But the square magnitude
of both of those
is 1 at that frequency.
OK, any questions about that?
Feel like I didn't say
that quite as clearly
as I could have?
OK.
So any questions about this?
OK, let's take a look
at another function
that we've been talking
about, a square wave.
In this case, you can see that
the square wave is symmetric
or even.
And you can see that the Fourier
transform of that is all real.
The peaks are in the real
part of the Fourier transform.
You can see the imaginary
part in red is 0 everywhere.
And you can see that the
Fourier transform of this
has multiple peaks
at intervals that
are again equal to the
frequency of this square wave.
OK?
If you look at the power
spectrum of the square wave,
you can see again it's
got multiple peaks
at regular intervals.
One thing that you
often find when
you look at power
spectra of functions
is that some of the peaks are
very low amplitude or very low
power.
So one of the
things that we often
do when we're
plotting power spectra
is to plot not power
here but log power.
OK?
And so we plot power
in log base 10.
A difference of an order
of magnitude in two peaks
corresponds to a unit
called a bel, b-e-l.
So 1 bel corresponds to a factor
of 10 difference in power.
So you can see this peak
here is about 1 bel lower
than that peak, right?
And more commonly used
unit is called decibels,
which are 10 decibels per bel.
So decibels are given
by 10 times the log
base 10 of the power of the
square magnitude of the Fourier
transform.
Does that make sense.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE]
square magnitude [INAUDIBLE]
so just like [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: No, so you take
this square magnitude because--
OK, remember, last time
we talked about power.
So if you have an electrical
signal, the power in the signal
would be voltage
squared over resistance.
Power, when you
refer to signals,
is often kind of used
synonymously with variance.
And variance is also goes
as the square of the signal.
Now, because the
Fourier transform
is a complex number, what we
do is we don't just square it,
but we take the
squared magnitude.
So we're measuring the
distance from the origin
in the complex plane.
OK?
Good question.
All right, any questions
about this and what
the meaning of decibels is?
So if a signal had 10
times as much amplitude,
the power would be
how much larger?
If you had 10 times
as much amplitude,
how much increased
power would there be?
100 times.
Which is how many bels?
Log base 10 of 100 is 2.
How many decibels?
AUDIENCE: 22?
MICHALE FEE: No, it's
10 decibels per bel.
Deci just means a
tenth of, right?
Remember those units?
So a factor of 10 in
signal is a factor of 100
in power, which is 2 bels,
which is 20 decibels.
OK.
All right, now I just want to
show you one important thing
about Fourier transforms.
There's an interesting
property about scaling
in time and frequency.
So if you have a signal like
this that's periodic at about--
I don't know, it looks like--
OK, there it is-- about 5 hertz.
If you look at the
Fourier transform of that,
you can see a series of peaks,
because it's a periodic signal.
Now, if you take
that same function
and you make it go faster--
so now, it's at about 10
hertz, instead of 5 hertz,
you can see that the Fourier
transform is exactly the same.
It's just scaled out.
So the faster something moves
in time, the more stretched
out the frequencies are.
Does that makes sense.
So if I show you any periodic
function at one frequency
and I show you the
Fourier transform of it,
you can immediately write
down the Fourier transform
of any scaled version
of that function,
because if this goes faster,
if this same function but
at a higher frequency, you
can write down the Fourier
transform just by taking
this Fourier transform
and stretching it out
by that same factor.
OK?
All right, so that was
just a brief review
of what we covered last time.
And here's what we're
going to cover today
in a little more detail.
So we're going to talk some
more about the idea of Fourier
transform pairs.
These are functions where
you have a function.
You take the Fourier
transform of it.
You get a different function.
If you take the Fourier
transform of that,
you go back to the
original function.
OK, so there are pairs of
functions that are essentially
for transforms of each other.
OK?
An example of that you saw here.
A square wave like this
has a Fourier transform
that's this funny
function a set of peaks.
If you take the four
transform of that,
you would get this square wave.
OK?
We're going to talk about the
convolution theorem, which
is a really cool theorem.
Convolution in the time domain
looks like multiplication
in the frequency domain.
Multiplication in
the time domain
looks like convolution
in the frequency domain.
And it allows you to take a
set of Fourier transform pairs
that you know, that we'll
learn, and figure out
what the Fourier transform is
of any function that's either
a product of those or a
convolution of those kind
of base functions.
It's a very powerful theorem.
We're going to talk
about the Fourier
transform a Gaussian noise and
this power spectrum of Gaussian
noise.
We'll talk about how to
do spectral estimation.
And we'll end up on the
Shannon-Nyquist theorem
and zero padding.
And there may be, if
there's time at the end,
I'll talk about a little
trick for removing the line
noise from signals.
OK, so let's start with
Fourier transform pairs.
So one of the most
important functions
to know the Fourier transform
of is a square pulse like this.
So let's just take
a function of time.
It's 0 everywhere, 0 everywhere.
But it's 1 if the time is
within the interval plus delta
t over 2 to minus
delta t over 2,
OK, so a square pulse like that.
And let's just
take the case where
delta t is 100 milliseconds.
The Fourier transform
of a square pulse
is a function called
the sinc function.
It looks a little bit messy.
But it's basically
a sine wave that
is weighted so that
it's big in the middle
and it decreases as
you move away from 0.
And it decreases as 1/f.
So this is frequency
along this axis.
It's just imagine that
you have a sine wave that
gets smaller as you go away
from the origin by an amount 1
over f.
That's all it is.
Now, really important
concept here, remember,
we talked about how you can
take a function of time.
So once you know that
the Fourier transform
of a square wave, of this square
wave of with 100 milliseconds,
is a sinc function.
You know what the
Fourier transform
is of a square
pulse that's longer.
Right?
What is it?
Remember, if you just
take a function in time
and you stretch it out,
the Fourier transform
just does what?
It compresses.
It shrinks.
And if you take this pulse and
you make it narrower in time,
then the Fourier transform
just stretches out.
So if we take that
pulse and we make
it narrower, 25
milliseconds, then
you can see that
the sinc function,
it's the same sinc function,
but it's just stretched out
in the frequency domain.
So you can see that here
if it's 10 milliseconds,
the width of this is 12 hertz.
The full width at half max
of that peak is 12 hertz.
If this is 4 times
narrower, then this width
will be 4 times wider.
What happens if we
have a pulse here that
is 500 milliseconds longer?
So 5 times longer, what's the
width of the sinc function
here going to be?
It'll be five times
narrower than this,
so a little over 2 hertz.
OK?
Does that makes sense.
So you should
remember this Fourier
transform pair, a square
pulse and a sinc function.
And there's a very important
concept called the time
bandwidth product.
You can see that as you make
the width in time narrower,
the bandwidth in
frequency gets bigger.
And as you make the
pulse in time longer,
the bandwidth gets smaller.
And it turns out that the
product of the width in time
and the width in frequency
is just a constant.
And for this square pulse sinc
function, that constant is 1.2.
So there's a limit.
If you make the
square pulse smaller,
the sinc function gets broader.
All right, let's look at a
different Fourier transform
pair.
It turns out that the Fourier
transform of a Gaussian
is just a Gaussian.
So, here, this Gaussian pulse
is 50 milliseconds long.
The Fourier transform of
that is a Gaussian pulse
that's 20 hertz wide.
If I make that Gaussian
pulses in time narrower,
then the Gaussian in
frequency gets wider.
And inversely, if I make
the pulse in time wider,
then the Gaussian in
frequency space gets narrower.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I just have
a question [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Yep.
So I'm trying-- it's a
little bit unclear here,
but I'm measuring these
widths at the half height.
OK, and so you can see that for
a Gaussian, this time bandwidth
product, delta f times
delta t is just 1.
So there's a time
bandwidth product of 1.
Who here has taken
any quantum mechanics?
Who here has heard of the
Heisenberg uncertainty
principle?
Yeah.
This is just the Heisenberg
uncertainty principle.
This is where the
Heisenberg uncertainty
principle comes from, because
wave functions are just--
you can think of wave functions
as just functions in time.
OK?
So the spatial localization
of an object is some--
the wave function is just
some position of space.
And the momentum
of that particle
can be computed as the Fourier
transform of the wave function.
And so if the
particle is more lo--
[AUDIO OUT] in space, then
if you compute the Fourier
transform of that
wave function, it's
more dispersed in momentum.
OK, so the uncertainty
in momentum is larger.
So this concept of
time bandwidth product
in the physical world is
what gives us the Heisenberg
uncertainty principle.
It's very cool.
Actually, before I go on, you
can see that in this case,
the Fourier transform of this
function is the same function.
Does anyone remember what
a [AUDIO OUT] function
is that the Fourier
transform of it
is another version of
that same function?
We talked about it last time.
AUDIENCE: Pulse train.
MICHALE FEE: Pulse
train, that's right.
So a train of delta functions
has a Fourier transform
that's just a train
of delta functions.
And 1 over spacing
in the time domain
is just equal to 1 over the
spacing in the frequency
domain.
So that's another
Fourier transform pair
that you should remember.
All right?
OK, convolution theorem.
Imagine that we have three
functions of time, y of t,
like this one, y of t.
We could calculate the
Fourier transform of that.
And that's capital Y of omega.
And then we have some
other function, x of t,
And its Fourier
transform, X of omega,
and another function g of tau
and its Fourier transform,
capital G of omega.
So remember, we can write down
the convolution of this time
series, x with this
kernel g as follows.
So in this case,
we're defining y
as the convolution of g with x.
So y of t equals this integral
d tau g of tau x of t minus tau,
integrating over all tau.
So that's a convolution.
The convolution theorem tells us
that the Fourier transform of y
is just the product of
the Fourier transform of g
and the Fourier transform of x.
So that, you should remember.
All right?
I'm going to walk you
through how you derive that.
I don't expect you to
be able to derive it.
But the derivation is kind
of cute, and I enjoyed it.
So I thought I'd
show you how it goes.
So here's the definition
of the convolution.
What we're going to do is
we're going to just take
the Fourier transform of y.
So here's how you calculate
Fourier transform of something.
Capital Y of omega is just the
integral over all time dt y
of t e to the minus i omega t.
So we're going to
substitute this into here.
Now, you can see that--
OK, so the first [AUDIO OUT]
is actually reverse
the order of integration.
We're going to integrate
over t first rather than tau.
Then what we're
going to do is we
can move the g
outside the integral
over t, because it's
just a function of tau.
So we pull that out.
So now, we have an integral
dt x of t minus tau
e to the minus i omega t.
And what we can do is do a
little modification here.
We're going to pull an e to the
minus i omega tau out of here.
So we have e to
the minus i omega
tau times e to the minus
j omega t minus tau.
So you can say if you multiply
those two things together,
you just get back to that.
Now, what we're going
to do is because this
is we're integrating over t, but
[AUDIO OUT] a function of tau,
we can pull that
out of the integral.
And now we have integral
dt x t minus tau
e to the minus i
omega t minus tau.
And what do you think that is?
What is that?
What would it be if
there were no tau there?
If you just cross that out
and that, what would that be?
Anybody know?
What that's?
AUDIENCE: The Fourier transform.
MICHALE FEE: This is just
the Fourier transform of x.
Right?
And we're integrating from
minus infinity to infinity.
So it does it matter if we're
shifting the inside by tau?
No, it doesn't
change the answer.
We're integrating from
minus infinity to infinity.
So shifting the inside of
it by a small amount tau
isn't going to do anything.
So that's just the
Fourier transform of x.
Good?
And what is this?
Fourier transform of g.
So the Fourier transform of y
is just Fourier transform of g
times the Fourier
transform of x.
All right, that's pretty cool.
Kind of cute.
But it's also really powerful.
OK, so let me show you
what you can do with that.
First, let me just
point out one thing
that there is a
convolution theorem that
relates convolution
in the time domain
to multiplication in
the frequency domain.
You can do exactly
the same derivation
and show that convolution of
two functions in the frequency
domain is the same as
multiplication in the time
domain.
So that's the
convolution theorem.
So let's see why
that's so powerful.
So I just showed you the
Fourier transform of a Gaussian.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to calculate transform of
a Gaussian times a sine wave.
So if you take a
Gaussian, some window
centered around 0
in time-- this is
a function of time now right?
So there's a little
Gaussian pulse in time.
We're going to multiply
that by this sine wave.
And when you multiply
those together,
you get this little
pulse of sine.
OK?
[WHISTLES] Sorry,
constant frequency.
Boy, that's harder
to do than I thought.
[WHISTLES] OK, just a
little pulse of sine wave.
So what's the forehead
transform of that?
Well, we don't know, right?
We didn't calculate it.
But you can actually
just figure it out very
simply, because you
know the Fourier
transform of a Gaussian.
What is that?
A Gaussian.
You know the Fourier
transform of a sine wave.
What is that?
Yeah.
Hold it up for me.
What does it look like?
Yes, sine wave,
thank you, like this.
OK.
And so what do you know--
what can you tell me right
away what the Fourier
transform of this is?
You take the Fourier
transform of that
and can involve it with the
Fourier transform of that.
So let's do that.
So there's the Fourier
transform of this Gaussian.
If this is 200 milliseconds
wide, then how wide is this?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: It's 1 over 200
milliseconds, which is what?
5 hertz, right?
1 over 0.2 is 5.
The Fourier transform
of this sine wave--
and I think I made it a
cosine instead of a sine.
Sorry, that's why I
was going like this,
and you were going like this.
So I made it a cosine function.
The Fourier transform of the
cosine function has two peaks.
This is 20 hertz.
So one peak at 20,
one at minus 20.
And the Fourier
transform of this
is just the convolution
of this with that.
You take this Gaussian and you
slide it over those two peaks.
You essentially
smooth this with that.
Does that makes sense?
Cool.
So you didn't actually have
to stick this into Matlab
and compute the Fourier
transform of that.
You can just know in
your head that that's
the product of a Gaussian
and a sine wave, or cosine.
And therefore, the
Fourier transform of that
is the convolution of a
Gaussian with these two peaks.
And there are
many, many examples
of interesting and useful
functions in the time domain
that you can
intuitively understand
what their Fourier transform
is just by having this idea.
It's very powerful.
Here's another example.
We're going to
calculate the Fourier
transform of this square
windowed cosine function.
So it's a product of the
square pulse with this cosine
to give this.
So what is the Fourier
transform of this.
What is that?
So what is the Fourier
transform of that?
AUDIENCE: The sinc function.
MICHALE FEE: It's
the sync function.
It's that kind of
wiggly, peaky thing.
And the Fourier transform
of that is just two peaks.
And so the Fourier transform of
this is just like two peaks--
yeah-- with wiggly
stuff around them.
That's exactly right.
All right, any
questions about that?
OK.
All right, change
of topic, let's
talk about Gaussian noise.
The Fourier transform of
noise and the power spectrum
of noise.
And we're going to
eventually bring
all these things back together.
OK?
All right, so what
is Gaussian noise?
So first of all, Gaussian
noise is a signal
in which the value at each
time is randomly sampled
from a Gaussian distribution.
So you can do that in Matlab.
That's a very simple function.
This returns a
vector of length N,
sampled from a normal
distribution, with variance 1.
So here's what that sounds like.
[STATIC NOISE]
Sounds noisy, right?
OK, I just wanted to show
you what the autocorrelation
function of this looks like,
which I think we saw before.
So if you look at the
distribution of all
the samples, it just
gives you a distribution
that it has the
shape of a Gaussian.
And the standard deviation
of that Gaussian is 1.
Now, what if you
plot the correlation
between the value of value
of this function at time t
and time t plus 1?
Is there any relation
between the value
of this function at any time
t and another time t plus 1?
So they're completely
uncorrelated with each other.
The value of time t is
uncorrelated with the value
of time t plus 1.
So there's zero correlations
between neighboring samples.
What about the correlation
of the signal at time
t with the signal at time t?
Well, that's perfectly
correlated, obviously.
So we can plot the correlation
of this function with itself
at different time lags.
Remember, that was the
autocorrelation function.
And if we do that, you
get a 1 at 0 lag and 0
at any other lag.
So that's the autocorrelation
function of Gaussian noise.
All right, now, the Fourier
transform of Gaussian noise
is just Gaussian noise.
It's another kind of interesting
Fourier transform pair.
And it's a Gaussian
distribution.
It's a Gaussian
random distribution
in both the real and
the imaginary part.
So you can see that
the blue and red--
the red here is the
imaginary part--
are both just Gaussian noise.
OK?
All right, now what
is the power spectrum?
So we can take this thing--
and, remember, when we
plot the power [AUDIO OUT]
just plot the square
magnitude of just
the positive frequencies.
Why is that again?
Why do we only have to
plot the square magnitude
of the positive frequencies?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] Gaussian,
so they're all [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Yep.
So it turns out that
the Fourier transform
in a positive frequency is
just the complex conjugate
of the Fourier transform
in the negative frequency.
So the square
magnitude is identical.
So the power
spectrum on this side
is equal to the power
spectrum on that side.
So we just plot half of it.
So that's what
the power spectrum
of this particular piece
of signal looks like.
The power spectrum of
noise is very noisy.
We're going to
come back, and I'm
going to show you
that on average,
if you take many different
signals, many copies of this,
and calculate the power
spectrum and average them all
altogether, it's
going to be flat.
But for any given
piece of noisy signal,
the power spectrum
is very noisy.
Any questions about that?
OK.
All right, so now let's
turn to spectral estimation.
How do we estimate the
spectrum of a signal?
So let's say you have
a signal, S of t.
And you have a bunch of short
measurements of that signal.
You have some signal,
let's say, from the brain,
like you record some local
field potential or some ECG
or something like that.
And you want to find
the spectrum of that.
Let's say you're
interested in measuring
the theta rhythm or
some alpha rhythm
or some other periodic
signal in the brain.
What you could do
is you could have
a bunch of independent
measurements of that signal.
Let's in this case call them
four trials, a bunch of trials.
What you can do is calculate
the power spectrum,
just like [AUDIO OUT] for
each of those signals.
So this is a little sample
y of t, y1 of t, y2 of t.
You can calculate the
square of magnitude
of the Fourier transform of
each one of those samples.
And you can estimate the
spectrum of those signals
by just averaging together
those separate, independent
estimates.
Does that make sense?
So literally, we just
do what we did here.
We have a little bit of signal.
We Fourier transform it,
take the square magnitude.
And now, you average together
all of your different samples.
Does that makes sense?
That's the simplest form
of spectral estimation.
It's like if you want to
estimate the average height
of a population of people.
You take a bunch of
different measurements.
You randomly sample.
You take a bunch of
different measurements.
And you average them together.
That's all we're doing here.
OK?
Now, you can apply that same
principle to long signals.
What you do is you
just take that signal
and you break it
into short pieces.
And you compute
the power spectrum
in each one of those windows.
And again, you
average them together.
Now, extracting that
little piece of signal
from this longer signal
is essentially the same
as multiplying that long
signal by a square pulse.
0 everywhere, but
1 in here, 1 here.
0 everywhere else.
Right?
So that process of
taking a long signal
and extracting out one
piece of it has a name.
It's called windowing.
Sort of like you're looking at
a scene through this window,
and that's all you can see.
OK, so one way to estimate
the spectrum of this signal
is to take the signal
in this window,
compute the FFT of that,
take this power spectrum.
And then apply this
window to the next piece.
Apply this window to the next
piece and compute the spectrum
and average them all altogether.
What's the problem with that?
Why might that be a bad idea?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Could we [INAUDIBLE].
MICHALE FEE: Good.
That's a very good example.
But there's sort of
a general principle
that we just learned that you
can apply to this problem.
What happens to the Fourier
transform of the signal
when we multiply it
by this square pulse?
AUDIENCE: Convolving.
MICHALE FEE: We're convolving
the spectrum of the signal
with a sinc function.
And the sinc function
is really ugly, right?
It's got lots of wiggles.
And so it turns out this
process of windowing
a piece of data with
this square pulse
actually does really
horrible things
to our spectral estimate.
And we're going to
spend a lot of time
in the next lecture
addressing how
you solve that problem
in a principled way
and make a good
estimate of the signal
by breaking it up
into little pieces.
But instead of just
taking a square window
we do something called tapering.
So instead of multiplying
this signal by square pulses,
we sample the signal
by applying it
by little things that look
like little smooth functions,
like maybe a Gaussian, or other
functions that we'll talk about
do an even better job.
OK?
All right.
OK, so that process is
called tapering, multiplying
your data by a little
[AUDIO OUT] paper
that's smooth, unlike
a square window.
Computing spectral estimates
from each one of those windowed
and tapered pieces of data
gives you a very good estimate
of the spectra.
And we're going to
come back to that,
how to really do that
right, on Thursday.
OK?
All right, let me point
out why this method
of spectral estimation
is very powerful.
So, remember, we talked
about how you can see--
remember, we talked about if
you have a noisy signal that
has a little bit of
underlying sine wave in it,
we talked about in
class, if you take
the autocorrelation
of that function,
you get a delta function and
then some little wiggles.
So there are ways of
pulling periodic signals,
periodic structure
out of noisy signals.
But it turns out
that this method
of spectral
estimation [AUDIO OUT]
did the most powerful
way to do it.
I'm just going to
show you one example.
This blue function
here is noise,
plus a little bit of a sine
wave at, I think it's 10 hertz.
OK, yeah.
Anyway, I didn't write
down the frequency.
But the blue function here is
noise plus the red function.
So you can see the
red function is small.
And it's buried in the noise,
so that you can't see it.
But when you do this process
of spectral estimation
that we're learning
about, you can
see that that signal
buried in that noise
is now very easily visible.
So using these methods, you can
pull tiny signals out of noise
at a very bad signal
to noise ratio,
where the signal is really
buried in the noise.
So it's a very powerful method.
And we're going to
spend more time talking
about how to do that properly.
All right, so let me spend a
little bit more time talking
about the power
spectrum of noise,
so that we have a better
sense of what that looks like.
So remember, I told
you if you take
a sample of noise like this
and you estimate the spectrum
of it, you compute the
power spectrum of one sample
of noise, it's extremely noisy.
Let's see, I'm just
going to remind you
what that looks like.
That's the power spectrum
of one sample of noise.
In order to estimate what the
spectrum of noise looks like,
you have to take
many examples of that
and average them together.
And when you do
that, what you find
is that the power spectrum
of noise is a constant.
It's flat.
[AUDIO OUT] Gaussian noise.
The power spectrum, really, you
should think about it properly
as a power spectral density.
There is a certain amount of
power at different frequencies
in this signal.
So there is some power
at low frequency,
some power at
intermediate frequencies,
some power at high frequencies.
And for Gaussian noise, that
power spectral density is flat.
It's constant as a
function of frequency.
OK?
And the units here have units
of variance per unit frequency--
variance per frequency.
OK?
Or if it were an
electrical signal
going through a
resistor, it would
be power per unit frequency.
So you can see that here
the value here is 0.002.
The bandwidth of this
signal is 500 hertz.
And so the variance
is the variance
per unit per unit frequency
times the bandwidth.
And that's 1.
And we started with
a Gaussian noise
that has variance 1, that
when we calculate the power
spectrum of that we
can correctly read out
from the power spectrum how
much variance there is per unit
frequency in the signal.
OK?
All right, it's kind
of a subtle point.
I actually don't expect
you to know this.
I just wanted you to
see it and hear it.
So you know formally
what it is that you're
looking at when you look
at a spectral estimate
of a noisy signal.
All right, let's talk about
filtering in the frequency
domain.
So remember, we learned
how to smooth a signal,
how to filter a signal,
either high pass or low pass,
by convolving a
signal with a kernel.
So you remember that the
kernel for a low pass
was something like this.
So when you convolve, that's
the kernel for a low pass.
And for a high pass, anybody
remember what that looks like?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Yep.
So-- sorry, I should be a little
more careful here not to mix up
my axes with--
I'm going to remove that.
So that's the kernel
for a low-pass filter.
The kernel for a
high-pass filter
is a delta function that
reproduces the function.
And then you subtract off
a low-pass filtered version
of the signal.
OK?
So that's the kernel
for a high pass.
OK, so this was how
you filter a signal
by convolving your signal with a
function, with a linear kernel.
We're going to talk now
about how you do filtering
in the frequency domain.
So if filtering
in the time domain
is convolving your
[AUDIO OUT] with a function,
what is filtering in the
frequency domain going to be?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Right.
It's going to be multiplying
the Fourier transform
of your signal times what?
AUDIENCE: The Fourier
transform [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: The Fourier
transform of things like that.
All right, so let's do that.
So this is what we
just talked about.
We introduced the idea before.
This was actually
a neural signal
that has spikes up here
and local field potentials
down here.
And we can extract the
local field potentials
by smoothing this [AUDIO OUT]
by low pass filtering it,
by convolving it with
this kernel here.
So this is what we
just talked about.
So if filtering
in the time domain
is convolving your
data with a signal,
then filtering in
the frequency domain
is multiplying the Fourier
transform of a [AUDIO OUT]
times the Fourier
transform of the kernel.
And you can see that what this
does to the power spectrum
is just what you would expect.
The power spectrum of
the filtered signal
is just the power spectrum
of your original signal
times the power
spectrum of the kernel.
All right, so here's an example.
So in blue is the
original Gaussian noise.
In green is the kernel
that I'm smoothing it by,
filtering it by.
Convolving the blue with the
green gives you the red signal.
What kind of filter
is that called again?
High pass or low pass?
AUDIENCE: Low pass.
MICHALE FEE: Low pass, good.
All right, so let me play
you what those sound like.
So here's the original
Gaussian noise.
[STATIC] Good.
And here's the low
pass Gaussian noise.
[LOWER STATIC] It got rid
of about the high frequency
parts of the noise.
OK, so here's the power spectrum
of the original signal in blue.
In order to get the power
spectrum of the filtered signal
in red, we're going to multiply
that by the magnitude squared
Fourier transform of this.
What do you think
that looks like?
So this is a little
Gaussian filter in time.
What is the Fourier transform
of that going to look like?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: The Fourier
transform of a Gaussian
is a Gaussian.
So the power spectrum
of that signal
is going to just be a Gaussian.
Now, how would I plot it?
It's peaked where?
The Fourier transform of
a Gaussian is peaked at 0.
So it's going to be a
Gaussian here centered at 0.
We're only plotting the
positive frequencies.
So this, we're ignoring.
And it's going to
be like that, right?
So that's the Fourier transform,
squared magnitude Fourier
transform of that Gaussian.
It's just another Gaussian.
And now if we multiply this
power spectrum times that power
spectrum, we get
the power spectrum
of our filtered signal.
Does that makes sense?
So convolving our original blue
signal with this green Gaussian
kernel smooths the signal.
It gets rid of high frequencies.
In the frequency domain,
that's like multiplying
the spectrum of the blue
signal by a function that's
0 at high frequencies
and 1 at low frequencies.
Does that makes sense?
So filtering in the frequency
domain, low filtering
in the frequency domain, means
multiplying the power spectrum
of your signal by a function
that's low at high frequencies
and big at low frequencies.
So it passes the
frequencies and suppresses
the high frequencies.
It's that simple.
Any questions about that?
Well, yes--
AUDIENCE: So why
is it that like--
you need to like--
of I guess when you
multiply in the frequency,
could you theoretically
multiply by anything
and that would correspond to
some other type of filter.
So why don't we just like
throw away high frequencies?
Or something like multiply by a
square in the frequency domain
and correspond to some
different filter we don't know.
MICHALE FEE: Yeah.
You can do that.
You can take a signal like this,
Fourier transform it, multiply
it by a square window to
suppress high frequencies.
What is that equivalent to?
What would be the
corresponding temporal kernel
that that would correspond to?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Good.
It would be convulsing your
function with a sinc function.
It turns out that's--
the reason you wouldn't
normally do that
is that it mixes the
signal across all time.
The sinc function
goes on to infinity.
So the nice thing about this
is when you smooth a signal
with a Gaussian, you're not
adding some of the signal here
that were over here.
Does that makes sense?
Convolving with a sinc function
kind of mixes things in time.
So normally you would
smooth by functions
that are kind of local in
time, local in frequency,
but not having sharp edges.
Does that makes sense?
So we're going to talk about how
to smooth things in frequency
with signals with kernels
that are optimal for that job.
That's Thursday.
What would a
high-pass filter look
like in the frequency domain?
So high-pass filter would
pass high frequencies
and suppress low frequencies.
Right?
You've probably not heard of
it, but, what would a band
pass filter look like?
It would just pass a band.
So it'd be 0 here.
It would be big
somewhere in the middle
and then go to 0 at
higher frequencies.
OK?
Does that makes sense?
Any questions about that?
OK.
Good.
If we plot this on a
log plot in decibels,
you can see that on a
log plot, a Gaussian,
which is e to [AUDIO OUT]
like f squared.
On a log plot, that's
minus f squared.
Right?
That's why on a
log plot this would
look like an inverted parabola.
So that's the same plot here,
but plotted on a log scale.
Any questions about that?
I want to tell you about a
cool little theorem called
the Wiener-Khinchin theorem
that relates the power
spectrum of a signal with the
autocorrelation of a signal.
So in blue, that's our
original Gaussian noise.
In red is our smooth
Gaussian noise.
If you look at the correlation
of neighboring time
points in the blue
signal, you can
see they're completely
uncorrelated with each other.
But what about neighboring time
points on the smooth signal?
Are they correlated
with each other?
If we look at for the
red signal, y of i
and y of i plus 1,
what does that look
like for the red signal?
They become correlated
with each other, right?
Because each value
of the smooth signal
is some sum over
the blue points.
So neighboring points here
will be similar to each other.
That's what smoothness means.
Neighboring time points
are close to each other.
So if you look at the
correlation of neighboring time
points in the smooth
signal, it looks like this.
It has a strong correlation.
So if you look at
the autocorrelation
of the original
Gaussian noise, it
has a delta function at zero.
The autocorrelation of
the smoothed function
has some width to it.
And the width to that
autocorrelation function
tells you the time [AUDIO OUT]
this signal was smoothed.
Right?
OK.
Now, how does that relate
to the power spectrum?
So it turns out that
the power spectrum
of a signal, the magnitude
squared of the Fourier
transform, the power
spectrum of the signal
is just the Fourier transform
of the autocorrelation.
So what's the Fourier
transform of a delta function?
Anybody remember that?
AUDIENCE: Constant.
MICHALE FEE: It's a constant.
And how about our smoothed?
Our smooth signal
has a power spectrum
that's a Gaussian in this case.
What's the transform
of a Gaussian?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: OK.
So if you have a signal that
you have some sense of what
the power spectrum
is you immediately
know what the
autocorrelation is.
You just Fourier transform that
and get the autocorrelation.
What's the width
of this in time?
How would I get that from here?
How are the width in time and
frequency related to each other
for--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Right.
The width of this
in time is just 1
over the width of
[AUDIO OUT] So you
have to take the full width.
Does that makes sense?
OK.
Wiener-Khinchin
theorem, very cool.
All right, let's talk about
the Shannon-Nyquist theorem.
Anybody heard of
the Nyquist limit?
Anybody heard of this?
All right, so it's a
very important theorem.
Basically anybody who's
acquiring signals in the lab
needs to know the
Shannon-Nyquist theorem.
It's very important.
All right, so
remember that when we
have discrete Fourier
transforms, fast Fourier
transforms, our frequencies are
discretized and so is our time.
But the discretization
in frequency
means that the
function is periodic.
Any signal that has discrete
components and frequencies
is periodic in time.
Remember, we started
with Fourier series.
And we talked about how if
you have a signal that's
periodic in time, that
you can write it down
as a set of frequencies
that are integer multiples
of each other.
Now, in these signals,
time is sampled discretely
at regular time intervals.
So what does that tell us
about the spectrum, the Fourier
transform?
AUDIENCE: It's periodic.
MICHALE FEE: It's also periodic.
OK, so discretely sampled in
frequency at regular intervals
means that the signal
is periodic in time.
Discretely sampled in time
means that the Fourier transform
is periodic.
Now, we don't usually
think about this.
We've been taking these
signals, sines and cosines
and square pulses
and Gaussian things,
and I've been showing
you discretely sampled
versions of those signals.
And I've been showing you
the Fourier transforms
of those signals.
But I've only been showing
you this little part of it.
In fact, really be thinking
that those discreetly sampled
signals have a Fourier transform
that's actually periodic.
There's another copy of that
spectrum sitting up here
at 1 over the sampling rate and
another copy sitting up here.
Remember, this is like a
train of delta functions.
The Fourier transform of
that is like another train
of delta functions.
So there are copies of this
spectrum spaced every 1
over delta t.
It's kind of a strange concept.
So the separation
between those copies
of the spectra in
the frequency domain
are given by 1 over
the sampling rate.
Any questions about that?
It's a little strange.
But we'll push on
because I think
it's going to be more clear.
So what this says is that if
you want to properly sample
this signal in time, you
need these [AUDIO OUT] copies
of its spectrum to be far
away so they don't interfere
with each other.
So what that means is that
you need the sampling rate
to be high enough--
the higher the sampling rate
is, the further these spectra
are in time.
Delta t is very small,
which means 1 over delta t
is very big.
The sampling rate
needs to be greater
than twice the
bandwidth of the signal.
[AUDIO OUT] bandwidth B.
So if the sampling rate is
less than twice the bandwidth,
what happens?
That means delta t is too big.
These copies of the spectrum
are too close to [AUDIO OUT]
and they overlap.
That overlap is
called aliasing--
a-l-i-a-s-i-n-g.
OK?
So you can see that if you
sample a signal at too low
a sampling rate and you look
at the spectrum of the signal,
you see that it has--
like you'll see this
part of the spectrum,
but you'll also
see this other part
of the spectrum kind of
contaminating the top
of your Fourier transform.
Does that makes sense?
OK.
So let me just say it again.
If your signal has some
bandwidth B that in order
to sample that signal
properly, your sampling rate
needs to be greater than
twice that bandwidth, 1, 2.
OK?
All right, any
questions about that?
Actually, there was
actually recently
a paper where somebody claimed--
I think I told you about
this last time-- there
was a paper where
somebody claimed to be
able to get around this limit.
And they were mercilessly
treated in the responses
to that paper.
So don't make that mistake.
Now, what's really cool
is that if the sampling
rate is greater than
twice the bandwidth,
something amazing happens.
You can perfectly
reconstruct the signal.
Now that's an amazing claim.
Right?
You have a [AUDIO OUT] time.
All right, it's wiggling around.
What this is saying
is that I can
sample that signal
at regular intervals
and completely ignore
what's happening
between those samples, have no
knowledge of what's happening
between those samples.
And I can perfectly
reconstruct the signal
I'm sampling at
every time point,
even though I didn't look there.
So how do you do that?
Basically, your sampled signal,
you're regularly sampled
signal, has this spectrum--
has this Fourier transform
with repeated copies
of the signal, repeated
copies of the spectrum.
So how would I recover the
spectrum's original signal?
Well, the spectrum of
the original signal
is just this piece right here.
So all I do is in the frequency
domain I take that part.
I keep this, and I
throw away all those.
In other words, I multiply my
Fourier transfer sampled signal
in the frequency domain
by a square pulse that's
1 here and 0 everywhere else.
Does that makes sense?
And when I inverse Fourier
transform that I've completely
recovered my original signal.
What is multiplying
this spectrum
by the square wave in the
frequency domain equivalent
to in the time domain?
AUDIENCE: So I
was going to ask--
MICHALE FEE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: So why do
you want to do that?
MICHALE FEE: Yeah, so
it's amazing, right?
It's cool.
So let me just what it is.
And then we can marvel at
how that could possibly be.
Multiplying this spectrum
by this square wave,
throwing away all those
other copies of the spectrum
and keeping that
one is multiplying
by a square wave in
the frequency domain,
which is like doing what?
AUDIENCE: Convolving.
MICHALE FEE: Convolving
the time domain sinc--
that regular train of
samples, convolving that
with a sinc function.
So let me just say that.
Here, we have a function
that we've regularly
sampled at these intervals.
If we take that function, which
is a bunch of delta functions
here, here, here,
here, just samples,
and we can evolve that
with a sinc function,
we perfectly reconstruct
the original signal.
Pretty wild.
So that's the
Nyquist-Shannon theorem.
What it says is that
we can perfectly
reconstruct the signal we've
sampled as long as we sample it
at a sampling rate
that's greater than twice
the bandwidth of the signal.
OK?
All right.
OK, good.
So there's this cute
trick called zero-padding,
where you don't
perfectly reconstruct
the original signal, but
basically you can interpolate.
So you can extract the
values of the original signal
times between where you
actually sampled it.
OK?
And basically the
trick is as follows.
We take our sampled signal.
We Fourier transform it.
And what we do is
we just add zeros.
We pad that Fourier
transform with zeros.
OK?
So we just take
positive frequencies
and the negative
frequencies, and we just
stick a bunch of zeros between
and make it a longer vector.
And then when we inverse
Fourier transform this,
you can see that you
have a longer array.
When you inverse
transform, inverse Fourier
transform, what
you're going to have
is your original samples
back, plus a bunch of samples
in between that
interpolate, that
are measures of the
original signal at the times
where you didn't measure it.
So you can essentially
increase the sampling rate
of your signal after the fact.
Pretty cool, right?
Again, it requires that you've
sampled at twice the bandwidth
of the original signal.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Like how do
you know the bandwidth
of the original signal if
you don't have samples?
MICHALE FEE: Good question.
How might you do that?
AUDIENCE: Can you like
[INAUDIBLE] different sampling
lengths to get [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: You could do that.
From nearly all
applications, you
have a pretty good sense of what
the frequencies are that you're
interested in a signal.
And then what you do
is you have to put
a filter between your experiment
and your computer that's
doing the sampling
that guarantees
that it's suppressed all the
frequencies above some point.
OK?
And that kind of filter is
called an anti-aliasing filter.
So in that case, even if your
signal had higher frequency
components, the
anti-aliasing filter
cuts it off so that there's
nothing at higher frequencies.
Does that makes sense?
Let me give you an
example of aliasing.
Let's say I had this
signal like this.
And I sample it here, here,
here, here, here, here.
I need to do regular intervals.
So you can see that if
I have a sine wave that
is close in frequency
to the sampling rate,
you can see that when
I sample the signal,
I'm going to see something
at the wrong frequency.
That's an example of aliasing.
OK?
OK, so here's an example.
We have a 20 hertz cosine wave.
I've sampled it at 100 hertz.
So I'm, you know, 5--
so what frequency would I
have to sample this in order
to reconstruct the cosine?
I'd have to sample
at least 40 hertz.
Here, I'm sampling at 100.
The delta t is 10 milliseconds.
So those are the blue points.
And now, if I do this
zero-padding trick,
I Fourier transform.
I do zero-padding
by a factor of 4.
That means if I take the
Fourier transform signal
and I'm now making that
vector 4 times as long
by filling in zeros, then I
inverse Fourier transform.
You can see that
the red points show
the interpolated values of that
function after zero-padding.
OK?
So it can be a
very useful trick.
You can also sample the
signal in the time domain
and then add a bunch of
zeros to it before you
Fourier transform.
And that gives you finer
samples in the frequency domain.
OK?
And I think that's--
so zero-padding
in the time domain
gives you finer spacing
in the frequency domain.
And I'll show you in more
detail how to do this
after we talk about tapering.
And it's very simple
code actually.
Matlab has built
into it the ability
to do zero-padding right
in the FFT function.
OK, let's actually
just stop there.
I feel like we covered
a lot of stuff today.